this week Google unveiled something
that's calling instant paps they're a
lot like normal apps except instead of
going into an app store and downloading
it and installing it on your phone you
click a link and an instant app is ready
to go so here's an example of an
apartment rentals app called supper so
imagine I'm looking for an apartment
with my wife and she sends me a link
she's been looking this up her app to
find some apartments she says hey do any
of these looks
work worth looking at but I don't have
the supper app installed in my phone but
I can just click on the link and it'll
bring up the supper app and I'll drop
right into that the page that she was
looking at I can flip through different
apartment listings I can look at the map
and pan around the map zoom in use all
the native capabilities for that and
then if I pick like an apartment I could
just click on it and then share it right
back to her as if I had you know gone
through installing the app and I had it
in my phone but when I'm done does not
perhaps not it's all my phone and longer
it's actually pretty clever
it works by taking a traditional habit
and chopping it into pieces each of
those pieces is called an atom each atom
is assigned a small subset of features
from the larger app because it's so
small it can open as quickly as a web
page and because it's only assigned
specific features it can perform those
specific tasks just as powerfully as the
traditional app developers can
modularize their apps and enable deep
linking in their apps and that means
that any time a user taps on one of
those deep links Google Play can
download just the parts of that app that
are needed to show the experience and
run it instantly so Google won't be
rolling out instant apps until later
this year but if they work as advertised
they can change the way you use your
smart phone forever